simple question does the Bible have
authority over the Constitution he said
that's a simple question I know it's a
question I say it straight to the
emaciation a simply worded question
how's that I think probably what you
have to do is ask a very specific
question about a specific passage of the
Bible and a specific portion of the
Constitution I don't think you can
answer that question other than out of
very specific context Carson clarified
his comments yesterday saying in an
interview quote Muslims feel that their
religion is very much a part of your
public life and what you do is a public
official and that's inconsistent with
our principles we have to stop listening
to these people who tell us that we
cannot talk about God we cannot talk
about our faith every coin in our pocket
every bill in our wallet says In God We
Trust but we're not supposed to talk
about it what in the world is that in
medicine we call it schizophrenia a form
of craziness so do you believe that
Islam is consistent with the
Constitution no i don't i do not i would
not advocate that we put a Muslim in
charge of this nation I absolutely would
not agree with that he said that's a
simple question he said that's a simple
question you know recently is a big
controversy you see when Carson he made
the statements about early derogatory
towards Islam and Muslims and we did a
show actually and we asked him to
comment about the Christian Sharia right
and now when he was actually asked
simple question does the Bible have
authority over the Constitution
regarding the Bible and the Constitution
it seemed like a difficult question for
him to answer what would you say on this
bigotry is one thing that ben Carson has
been guilty of yeah another is hypocrisy
in this instance he was asked a simple
question it was in fact a simple
question simply and he said this is not
such a simple question that's because
he's a hypocrite that's because he
believes his religion can should may
trump the Constitution when he deems fit
and many who support him believe like
him and then they turn around and
accused Muslims and Islam of being a
threat to the Constitution with
Korea that's in fact not at all true
first of all Muslims in this country are
two million people according to some
Paul's six to seven million according to
others we're talking with his group of
people 50 to 60 million you know
evangelicals right-wing Christians etc
who believe in the Bible trumping the
Constitution now when you look at the
Muslim community that's not the
direction we're going we're not
interested in Sharia pipping the
Constitution sure he has something that
can be practiced without in any way
conflicting with the Constitution in
personal affairs and that's the
direction would take and that's the
extent of it there's no interest there's
no movement there's no money being
pumped in there there are no candidates
being run in order to do otherwise at
the federal level of the state level at
any government level like what his
community is doing secondly when you
talk about that group of people you're
talking about billions of dollars are
being raised it's not just that they're
50 to 60 million people but billions of
dollars in political power money and
then they're running candidates yeah
Mike Huckabee they have this guy they
have others they have a tea party have
you heard of the Hubble hookah party I
haven't you know the Tea Party is the
one that's out there yeah Muslims aren't
putting together you know a massive
movement to put the Quran above the
Constitution the way that group of
people are doing with the Bible to pick
the Constitution so here's a hypocrite
in that in that sense and oftentimes you
see this Sharia scare as being nothing
more than mirrors and smoke screens to
sort of deflect attention and point at
someone else this is projection and say
their religion is going to threaten our
Constitution whereas that's exactly what
the evangelical right-wing Christian
movements in this country and their
candidates and their super PACs and
their websites and their blogs and their
TV stations on cable AM radio etc are
essentially out to do and that is the
religious threat to this constitution
that many people are not talking about